[Musik]
corona nachgehakt was wir bisher wissen
ja wir berichten ihnen immer über den
neuesten stand des wissens über das
virus und heute lautet unsere frage
welche fortschritte gibt es in der
behandlung der krankheit und also
begrüße ich professor hendrik speck
leiter der virologie an der uniklinik in
bonn herzlich willkommen
ja solange es keinen impfstoff gibt
müssen wir hoffen dass wir fortschritte
machen bei der behandlung der krankheit
und da gibt es jetzt laut whu einen
lebensrettenden durchbruch dexamethason
ja dexamethason ist eigentlich ein altes
medikament das ist ein kortison relativ
niedrig dosiert und das wurde schon für
viele jahre angewandt bei schweren
viralen pneumonien aber es wurde nie
getestet was eigentlich der einfluss ist
oder wie gut es eigentlich wirkt das war
so ein gefühl von den lungenärzten von
den intensivmediziner aber es wurde nie
wirklich verglichen und getestet und das
hat wirklich erstaunliche erfolge
gezeigt und man kann es sogar auch
erklären also man kann es auch
pathologisch erklären ja also das war
jetzt eine groß angelegte studie der
universität oxford an insgesamt 2.000
patienten die das mittel bekommen haben
4000 patienten war die kontrollgruppe
also das sehr sehr groß und das
erstaunliche ist jetzt dieses
dexamethason das bekämpft gar nicht das
virus das müssen sie jetzt erklären ja
also man muss das so sehen ganz am
anfang kommt das virus in den körper
rein und das wird vom immunsystem als
feind gesehen also das immunsystem
stürzt sich drauf und wird aktiviert und
viele verschiedene arme des immunsystems
viele verschiedene zellen gehen dagegen
vor
und dann wird es so viel dass irgendwann
dieser armee dieses am immunsystem
einfach viel zu stark ist und gegen viel
zu viele bereiche vorgeht dass man jetzt
quasi die armee wieder zurückpfeifen
muss das sein
nicht mehr so aggressiv vorgeht denn das
immunsystem kann unheimlich aggressiv
sein das wissen wir von
autoimmunerkrankungen wo wirklich das
immunsystem auf den körper zerstören
kann und mit dexamethason wird das
immunsystem gedämpft und dadurch scheint
es sehr viel besser im aus also im
verlauf für die schwer erkrankten kurve
19 patienten zu sein
aber damit ist sehr klar es ist
ungeheuer wichtig in welchem moment bei
wem man dieses medikament einsetzt denn
merke wir bekämpfen ja das eigene
immunsystem
ja das ist ganz wichtig also man darf
jetzt wenn manche mögen das sogar bei
sich zu hause haben wenn sie zum
beispiel arthritis haben oder so das
ganz wichtig dass man das nicht einfach
nimmt denn dann macht man vielleicht am
anfang einer erkrankung sogar schwerer
also das ist das paradoxe daran dass
bevor man infiziert ist dann soll das
immunsystem ganz stark und ganz aktiv
sein
aber dann wenn man einen schweren
verlauf hat und nur dann kann
dexamethason wirken wissen wir denn was
jetzt bei 19 patienten passiert die in
dieser kritischen schlussphase sind wo
das eigene immunsystem überreagiert was
passiert denn da genau welche organe
werden geschädigt was macht das
immunsystem also wir wissen es natürlich
nicht ganz genau aber was wir beobachtet
haben im blut das ist ein so genannter
zytokin sturm das sind botenstoffe die
von immunzellen raus gesandt werden und
wirklich alles aktivieren und durch
diesen sturm wird eine panik im körper
ausgelöst und viele verschiedene
bereiche durch das immunsystem
angegriffen
das virus selber natürlich sobald es in
der lunge ist kann dann auch eher mal
ins blut übertreten und auch andere
bereiche des körpers schäden wissen wir
denn dieses überschießende immunsystem
wie häufig das vorkommt dass das am ende
sogar zum exitus des patienten führt bei
coop 19
ja also da sind wir auch nur erst am
anfang und wir können jetzt nicht sagen
warum das immunsystem plötzlich über
schießt oder nicht
aber der tödliche verlauf ist meistens
ja dann die pneumonie an sich also diese
lungenerkrankungen inwieweit da das
immunsystem dann wirklich die ursache
für den tod des patienten ist oder
generell der allgemeinzustand das wissen
wir natürlich nicht
jetzt hat sich ja schon immer wieder
ankündigungen gegeben ein neues
wundermittel und noch ein wundermittel
und die hoffnungen sind bisher alle zur
platz deshalb bisher noch kein mittel
gegeben dass die sterblichkeit von kogit
19 signifikant senkt dieses mittel jetzt
dexamethason können wir da
zuversichtlich sein dass das mehr ist
als nur ein erneutes wundermittel was
wir wieder verschwindet es zeigt uns
dass er die pathologie der der
erkrankung sehr viel besser erkennen und
verstehen also ist es schon ein alleine
jetzt kommen da die drei punkte zusammen
nicht nur macht es biologisch sinn
immunologisch sind dass dieses
medikament funktioniert sondern auch in
dieser groß angelegten studie zeigt es
wirklich eindeutig diesen effekt so dass
wir darauf erst mal vertrauen können
anders ist es mit anderen medikamenten
die in der gleichen studie getestet
wurden die nicht so guten erfolg erzielt
haben nochmals dexamethason das soll bei
den patienten die künstlich beatmet
wurden eine reduzierung der
sterblichkeit um ein drittel gebracht
haben das wäre wenn sie es denn
bewahrheitet auch außerhalb des studio
wirklich enorm das wäre natürlich enorm
und es würde auch bestätigen was
mediziner schon vermutet haben bei
influenza und anderen viralen pneumonien
also es wird uns nicht nur helfen
für schwere lungen gerade
lungenerkrankungen jetzt bei coop 19
sondern wahrscheinlich auch in der
behandlung von influenza oder anderen
schweren viralen erkrankungen wie fühlt
wie verfügbar ist dieses mittel wie
teuer das ist eigentlich ein relativ
billiges medikament weil es gibt auch
keine patente mehr auf dexamethason so
dass das auch ein medikamentes was
generell gut herzustellen ist und gut
verfügbar
ansonsten gibt es ja noch ein medikament
was in der frühphase eingesetzt werden
kann das ist rem de silva
das offensichtlich auch der folgezeit
rennen diese bier ist ein antivirale
medikament so dass direkt das virus an
greift nämlich es wirkt als in den
prozess in den stoffwechsel des virus
also das benutzt der teile der der zelle
als virus da also in ihrem eigenen
stoffwechsel benutzt dass teile der
zelle und bringt einige ins eigene
enzyme rein und diese enzyme werden
speziell geblockt
silvia hat aber leider nur eine
wirksamkeit wahrscheinlich in der
frühphase der erkrankung was bedeutet
das wenn man das im späteren verlauf
nimmt also wenn jemand auf
intensivstationen ist da wahrscheinlich
kaum noch eine gute wirkung zeigt aber
in den ersten stunden in den ersten
tagen wahrscheinlich dort sehr viel
effektiver sein wird als man bisher
beobachtet hat also wir haben was für
die frühphase ramsey wir und wir haben
was für die spätphase wenn das
immunsystem überschießen nämlich
dexamethason es gab ja immer
widersprüchliche meldungen über die
wirksamkeit von malaria mitteln
besonders in den schlagzeilen war hydrox
chloroquin das mittel dass donald trump
empfohlen hat sind wir da inzwischen
schlauer
ja also ich mit roxy kloock wien das ist
sogar der versuch also ist ja ein groß
angelegter versuch auch gewesen der ist
in der frühphase abgebrochen worden weil
gezeigt hat dass es keinen effekt hat
sondern eher schädlich ist das
einzunehmen mit roxy chloroquin und das
ist manchmal auch das besondere im labor
funktioniert es wunderbar gegen das
virus also es hemmt die replikation des
virus aber es wirkt eben nicht im
menschen und daher ist es wichtig dass
medikamente nicht basierend auf glauben
oder empfindungen von ärzten gegeben
werden sondern wirklich basierend auf
solchen groß angelegten studien manchmal
braucht es ja gar kein neu entwickeltes
medikament sondern man muss die
krankheitsverläufe nur ein bisschen
besser
kennenlernen und verstehen und dann hat
man jetzt festgestellt dass bei der
kogit 19 erkrankung sehr viele patienten
lebensgefährliche thrombosen bekommen
was hat man daraus gelernt nun die dass
es bedeutet wahrscheinlich dass das
virus auch häufiger über treten kann
in das blutsystem wir sehen im übrigen
bei schweren verläufen immer mal wieder
virus im blut
und wir wissen von anderen coronaviren
das coronaviren manchmal ein blutgefäß
entzündung verursachen kann und bei
einer blutgefäß entzündung kann es sehr
schnell zu einer thrombose bildung
kommen also die diese
blutgerinnungsstörung und das hat man
vermehrt bei schweren verläufen gesehen
hier in deutschland auf eine
intensivstation wird das heparin über
einen per fuß gegeben also direkt ins
blut geht blutsystem in italien zum
beispiel wird es ins unterhautfettgewebe
nur gespritzt bei schweren verläufen
dadurch dass ich das also das
blutgefäßsystem zentralisiert bei
schweren verläufen und gar nicht so gut
die haut mehr durchblutet wird passiert
ist dass dieses heparin was eigentlich
lebensnotwendig in solchen fällen ist in
italien häufig gar nicht angekommen ist
und häufig gar nicht ja wirken konnte
weil es gar nicht abgebaut wurde soll
die deutsche rentner daraus gelernt und
macht das jetzt so wie sie es
beschrieben haben also ich sag mal so
lauter kleine fortschritte die wir da in
der behandlung machen die in der summe
natürlich einiges bewirken können wie
viel können wir nachher noch darüber
reden
das eigentliche ziel wäre natürlich dass
die menschen überhaupt nicht erkranken
an komik 19
dazu braucht es einen impfstoff wie weit
sind wir da ja also impfstoffforschung
ist natürlich sehr komplex und es ganz
schwer vorherzusagen ob man einen
impfstoff haben wird oder nicht
wir haben gegen die größten
infektiologen killer der welt also
malaria tuberkulose denn die hiv haben
wir keinen impfstoff obwohl extrem stark
daran geforscht wird
man muss es diesen impfstoff konstrukt
ja immer erst mal menschen testen und
schauen ob er funktioniert
und erst dann kann man sagen ob es
sinnvoll ist diesen impfstoff zu
benutzen
der impfstoff von asta zenica der jetzt
mit optionen gekauft wurde von der
bundesregierung der hat im affen ja auch
keinen prophylaktischen schutz gezeigt
sondern hat gezeigt dass er wenn sich
jemand infiziert das ja dann nur einen
milden verlauf hat man sie mit anderen
worten da ist auch ein mittel mit sehr
viel hoffnung gestartet und jetzt haben
wir zumindest teilweise eine
enttäuschung weil es die erkrankung als
solche nicht verhindert sondern nur
einen schweren verlauf ja aber auch
einen schweren verlauf zu vermindern ist
natürlich extrem wichtig und auch aus
dem tierversuch können wir ja nicht
direkt schlussfolgern dass es im
menschen nicht wirklich
vielleicht bringt das keinen schutz im
affen aber könnte ein schutz im menschen
vor
jetzt hat er im lauf der woche sehr viel
schlagzeilen gemacht dass die
bundesrepublik über die kreditanstalt
für wiederaufbau kfw eingestiegen ist
bei der tübinger impfstoff firma cure
weg was für einen ansatz verfolgen die
nun ihr comeback hat einen sehr neuen
ansatz einen impfstoff zu machen indem
sie nur die erna also quasi das eine
andere form der dna benutzt und das in
den menschen gibt als im stoff das
bedeutet dass dann in den zellen wo die
erna rein gespritzt wurde die proteine
gebildet werden und die proteine des
virus und dadurch der impfstoff
aktiviert wird das ist ein sehr
geschicktes konzept aber es gibt eine
sache die man dabei bedenken muss dass
auf dieser basis bisher noch kein
einziger impfstoff weltweit zugelassen
wurde
auch wenn es interessant wirklich
interessantes konzept ist kann man hier
auch nicht sagen
dieser impfstoff wird jemals
produktreife erlangen insgesamt sind
weltweit derzeit circa 100 eben stoffe
in verschiedensten stufen der
entwicklung und der erprobung kann man
da eine prognose wagen wann können wir
mit einem wirklich funktionierenden
impfstoff rechnen
nein leider nicht also
gerade im hiv bereich haben wir das ja
sehr schmerzhaft gelernt in hiv sind wir
ja immer noch in der pandemie die wo
auch jeden tag sich neue menschen
infizieren
es gibt über 400 impfstoff konstrukte
die getestet wurden kein einziger von
denen hat funktioniert da vorherzusagen
ob es ein corona virus impfstoff gibt
ist natürlich sehr schwer und eigentlich
nicht machbar also an der stelle keine
prognose oder keine entfernung möglich
das heißt wir sind wieder da wo man
anfangen dieser sendung waren dass wir
gesagt haben wir müssen auf fortschritte
in der behandlung hoffen
jetzt blicke ich mal ein bisschen weiter
in die ferne kann es uns gelingen durch
medikamente die die krankheit behandelt
durch fortschritte bei der behandlung
lauter kleine schritte kann es sein dass
wir da die sterblichkeit so weit drücken
dass wir in den bereich der
sterblichkeit von griff bekommen also
ich nehme schon an dass die behandlung
immer besser werden wird und dass hier
auch immer mehr damit lernen damit
umzugehen
das neue virus wird ein teil unseres
alltags und wir werden lernen wie wir
gerade die person die einen schweren
verlauf haben könnten besser schützen
können es kann ja auch sein dass wir
medikamente entwickeln die die man
einnimmt die einem vor einer
infektionsschutz das ist viel
wahrscheinlicher dass das in den
nächsten jahren entwickelt wird als dass
wir auch einen impfstoff haben werden
also ein chemische substanz geht man
einnimmt die 1
jedes mal vor einer infektion schützen
das war corona nagt diesmal mit
professor hendrik speck herzliche dank
vielen dank